today we're going to explore what it's
like to create your first google
kubernetes engine cluster
in our gke essentials cluster modes
video we went over the differences
between gk standard mode and gk
autopilot mode clusters
now we'll put that knowledge into action
by creating one of each i'm caslin
fields and i'm a developer advocate here
at google cloud where i focus on google
kubernetes engine as well as the open
source kubernetes project
so today we're going to explore
creating your first gk cluster
[Music]
we're going to deploy our clusters today
using the google cloud console there are
many ways to deploy and manage your
clusters but the console is a great
place to start if you want to learn
what's possible
from here we're going to go to the
navigation menu on the upper left and
find kubernetes engine
in the compute section
you could also use the search bar at the
top and search for kubernetes or google
kubernetes engine
now we're in the gke section of the
console
since autopilot mode is still relatively
new you can see some information here
about what autopilot mode is along with
an option to try a demo where you will
create an autopilot mode cluster and
deploy a workload into it
below that you'll see any existing gke
clusters along with information about
them such as their name location
mode and resources
let's try to create a cluster by
clicking on the create button at the top
of this page
the console prompts us by asking whether
we would like to create a standard mode
cluster or an autopilot mode cluster
as well as providing a link to
additional information about the
differences
so let's go ahead and start by creating
an autopilot mode cluster
on this page there's some information
about what creating an autopilot mode
cluster will give you and there are some
input fields where we will need to
specify information about our cluster
first we can specify a name
then what region we would like to run
this cluster in
remember all autopilot mode gke clusters
are regional clusters meaning they're
deployed across the zones that make up a
region so there's no need to specify a
zone here
you could simply hit create at the
bottom of the page to create the cluster
at this point but let's take a look at
the additional options that you may wish
to configure
if we scroll down we can see some
expandable sections for networking
and advanced options in networking if
you choose to create a public cluster
then your nodes will be provisioned with
externally accessible ip addresses so
that you could reach the nodes from
anywhere over the internet
you can also enable control plane
authorized networks
in order to block untrusted
non-gcp source ips from accessing the
kubernetes master through https
a private cluster will be one where the
nodes are only accessible via private
ips on google cloud's network
the nodes of a private cluster only
communicate via the private google cloud
network
you can configure cloud network address
translation or cloud nat for your nodes
in order to for them to send outbound
requests to the internet
in advanced options if we scroll down
here
you can see uh configuration options for
the release channel for your gke cluster
when you enroll a new cluster in a
release channel google automatically
manages the version and upgrade cadence
for that cluster and its node pools
your choice of release channel between
rapid and regular and stable
will affect how quickly
new versions of kubernetes become
available for your cluster to upgrade
and how often your cluster must upgrade
to stay in compliance with the currently
supported versions of kubernetes
so for this cluster i'm just gonna go
with the default which is the regular
channel
if you'll need to specify acceptable
maintenance windows for your gke cluster
you can select enable maintenance window
here you must allow at least 48 hours of
maintenance availability in a 32-day
rolling window and a maintenance window
must allot at least four hours in order
to be considered
these options help you provide optimal
availability of your cluster while
allowing google to ensure that your
clusters are kept up to date with
supported kubernetes patches and
upgrades
you can also specify metadata and labels
in order to keep your cluster resources
organized
the description field here can be used
to provide a description for this
cluster's purpose or any other
information you wish to use to describe
it for example i could put in gke
gke essentials cluster
labels can be used to help organize
resources within your project for
example you could use labels such as
prod dev or test to indicate the use of
different clusters or you could specify
a team name to indicate that this
cluster is intended for use by that team
there are many ways that you could use
labels and metadata to keep your cloud
resources organized
now at the bottom of this page we can
use the create button to go ahead and
create the cluster that we've configured
or cancel to exit the page without
creating the cluster
you can also use the rest or command
line options here to get the rest api
call or command for use with the g cloud
cli
in order to create this cluster using
the cli or other automation
so let's go ahead and create this
cluster now using the create button here
so you'll see that our cluster is now
creating its status is this
currently being created a rolling circle
here you'll also notice here at the
upper right we have a notification icon
where the circle is going as well when
our autopilot mode gke cluster has
finished creating will receive a
notification on this notification icon
indicating that the cluster is ready
now let's go back to create
where we will explore configuring a
standard mode gke cluster you can see
that the format of the page for creating
a standard mode cluster
is already a little bit different
the sections you'll need to go through
to configure your gk standard mode
cluster are displayed on the left hand
side here the center contains the input
fields where you'll specify your
configuration information
and the right hand side gives a summary
of the cluster you'll create
including any cluster setup guides used
immutable properties that you won't be
able to change once the cluster is
created
billing information about the cluster
that you're going to be creating and its
resources any beta properties that
you'll be using
the limitations on the size of the
cluster
as well as information about the node
pools and the actual instances that will
make up your cluster
so our first tasks again are to select a
name for the cluster and a zone or
region while autopilot mode clusters can
only be regional standard mode clusters
may also be configured to run in only
a single zone within a region so you can
learn more about the differences between
zonal and regional clusters in our
documentation for this cluster i'll just
go ahead and make it a zonal cluster
with the default here
again you'll need to choose a release
channel
to determine the frequency of kubernetes
patches and upgrades however in standard
mode you may also choose to create a gke
control plane using a static version of
kubernetes using a static version will
require taking responsibility for
managing your cluster's version and
ensuring the cluster is using a
supported version of kubernetes
now we could stop here and go ahead and
create our cluster but let's quickly
review the additional configuration
options for a standard mode gke cluster
in the node pool section over here you
can configure the number of worker nodes
for your gke cluster
you can enable auto scaling as well as
node auto upgrade and node auto repair
you can also select
the number of nodes for your default
node pool
in the nodes section within the default
node pool we can see more information
about the nodes themselves such as
choosing the machine type as well as the
image the operating system that will be
configured on those nodes
in security you can configure service
accounts cloud api access scopes
and shielded node options
in the metadata section here
you can add labels specifically for the
nodes of your cluster rather than labels
that will be applied to the cluster as a
whole
you can also specify kubernetes node
taints at this stage to help you manage
what workloads will be able to run on
this node pool
within the cluster section
you can configure cluster level settings
pertaining to automation
networking security
metadata and additional cluster features
so in the automation section is where
you can configure maintenance windows as
we did in autopilot mode as well
in the cluster networking section you
can configure public or private clusters
as we saw in autopilot mode however
standard mode also includes some
additional advanced networking options
so you might want to take a look at
those
and in security you can enable shielded
or confidential nodes
secret encryption workload identity
google groups for our back and some
legacy security options here
in metadata you can configure cluster
level description data and labels as we
saw with autopilot mode
and in features you can configure
additional google cloud features such as
cloud run for anthos
enabling cloud logging and monitoring
and additional capabilities such as
cloud tpus istio and more
again at the bottom of this page
once you've configured all of your
options you can go ahead and create the
cluster that you've configured you can
cancel or you can get the rest or gcloud
cli command to create this cluster now
i'll choose to create and go ahead and
begin creation of this cluster
the cluster will take several minutes to
create as google cloud is spinning up
the compute resources that uh configure
the cluster according and and configures
the cluster according to your
specifications
you can see that the autopilot mode
cluster is still uh working on
completing here
uh once it's done it will be indicated
by a check mark as you see here on the
existing clusters
and you may also notice that in an
autopilot mode cluster there are no
number of nodes indicated
and for the one that's creating there's
no vcpu or memory indicated because
there are no workloads running on it so
when you do have a workload running on
it it will indicate how many vcpu and
memory are being used but you won't be
able to see the number of nodes because
in autopilot mode
the nodes of your kubernetes cluster are
not accessible and you will not be able
to see them in the console
and as you can see from the existing
standard mode cluster in this project
when the standard mode cluster
finishes its creation you'll see the
number of nodes as well as the total
amount of vcpu and memory that are
available to workloads running on that
cluster there's also a notification here
that indicates that i'm not running
enough workloads to be using this
this cluster efficiently
so autopilot mode provides a streamlined
gk cluster creation process with smart
defaults applying google's recommended
best practices for high availability and
securing hardening for your cluster the
pay per workload model of gk autopilot
clusters may also help increase resource
usage efficiency and thus optimize costs
as you pay only for the resources you
use the higher degree of management
provided by autopilot mode results in a
cluster creation process with fewer
overall configuration options the goal
being to get you to the stage where you
can run your workloads on kubernetes
faster
standard mode clusters offer more
flexibility and control but also require
you to think more carefully about the
many considerations that can go into
your gke standard mode clusters
configuration whether autopilot or
standard mode gke aims to provide you
with the tools you need to be successful
running your applications on kubernetes
in google cloud with the concepts
discussed in this video we're confident
you'll be on your way to building a gk
cluster that suits your needs
you can get started with gke by visiting
the google cloud console as we've
explored in this video
and check out the links below for
additional guides and resources
and stay tuned for our next videos where
we dive deeper into gke topics
you